first things first you're here in DC and
I know you're a busy woman what brought
you all the way out to DC my buddy
Gladys Knight is being honored which she
is so deserving of it I opened for her
actually
um many moons ago and so when the
Kennedy Center Honors asked me to be a
part of the artist committee this year I
was so thrilled that they were honoring
her
um of course who doesn't love George
Clooney I mean I mean it was worth
getting on the plane just just for him I
think about him you know what this will
be my first time actually meeting him of
course I've always talked about him and
reported on him so and Amy Grant and you
know YouTube who doesn't love them so
this is just a wonderful night and I
grew up watching the Kennedy Center
Honors so I'm just happy to be here
happy to be part of the committee now
are you doing anything on stage tonight
for Gladys I'm going to just scream
cheerleader in the front room if they
need a pimp I could be a pipette
I love it you are a woman of many
talents and I have to tell you you know
it was so Bittersweet watching the real
come to an end it was a show that was so
beloved and cherished by people like me
around the world now that it's been a
few months has it set in that that
chapter is over oh definitely and you
know what it allows me I just did
another movie I'm doing uh work with
Kennedy Center I'm doing uh other
projects so that's the thing about when
you're a comedian like me you're
multifaceted and you're doing other you
know things so I mean I love the girls
we still keep in contact is group chat
alive oh the group chat I mean they got
kids now Adrian just had a baby you know
I have to you know still be Auntie
Lonnie so it's bittersweet but you know
what we're all moving on and it's a
great thing we live in an age of reboots
and revivals if there was a chance to
get the real 2.0 booted up would you be
a part of it oh definitely I mean
I don't know but you know what
everybody's so busy now you know it's
like get a whole new group of girls okay
that's what I say well listen you and I
have spoken about how much we love Kiki
Palmer I know you congratulated her on
Instagram last night have you spoken
with her since this big reveal you know
what we were dming each other because
I've been trying to keep it a secret
I was like I was like okay you know
Auntie Lonnie gonna be quiet but I just
love the way that she did it and we're
just so happy for her and she's happy
and healthy and that's what matters
congratulations Kiki I love it chances
of you and her may be sitting on a panel
together getting a little show going you
know we already tried that remember we
tried that and
she ended up going to gma3 and then I
ended up going to the real so look we're
doing other things now okay Auntie
Lonnie you're gonna be around for
babysitting right yes I am
[Music]